m'attribu était au seuil de la plus
grande de ces victoires la dernière des
chouette avait été localisée les secrets
de l'émeraude de l'enclos étaient sur le
point d'être notre mais mon père m'a
empêché de me joindre au combat le
moment viendrait où je pourrais honorer
ma tribu mais ce moment n'était pas venu
ce furent les derniers mots qu'il
m'adressa et je ne l'ai jamais revu
toi et moi on a tout perdu ce jour-là
au revoir c'est lui
[Musique]
non non c'était pas un piège
prend la boussole et bâtons
[Musique]
réveille-toi il aide son ami renard au
lieu de reconquérir la boussole bien
entendu nouvel ami mais toujours cette
faiblesse pathétique
oh non non non ok on a un gros problème
là s'il te plaît nous emmène loin d'ici
réveille-toi
salut les jeunes je vous souhaite un bon
bain de glace
[Musique]
allez tu vas y arriver
il faut que je speed
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je veux pas mourir comme ça ça donne
d'originalité
tiens la porte à papa
j'ai compris il y a des pièges prévus
toutes les 7 secondes
[Musique]
ça faisait pas cette seconde
au moins celui-ci a raté
moustache
le petit laideron rouge je sais que tu
as hâte de trouver ton émeraude chéri
mais est-ce qu'on peut être un peu plus
attentif à ce qui nous entoure tu
permets
à gauche plus malin moins beau
et si tu veux cette émeraude tu vas
devoir te battre contre moi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'équipe né ne fait pas de
quartier ce n'est qu'un cœur mais après
si t-il vraiment le piquant de la vie
je voulais pas en arriver là mais tu me
laisses pas beaucoup le choix
[Musique]
trop facile finissons-en
pas tranquille pour mourir avec son
odeur je vais y réfléchir ok j'ai
réfléchi merci mais non merci
salut ma précieuse
alors toi tu fais pas semblant
hérisson
avec l'émeraude crois-tu que cette
phrase fera diversion
un instant ce n'est pas ce qui était
convenu
es pour rien un esprit plus évolué
aurait vu le couvenir à un kilomètre au
moins ou 0,6 miles je te faisais
confiance nous sommes comme frère
[Rires]
partout j'ai cru que tu plaisais que ce
soit ma première et dernière leçon petit
furoncle céleste un ami c'est empathique
honnête et ouvert aux besoins de l'autre
ce qui veut dire que X au carré fois
l'hypoténuse de y² / la valeur absolue
de la mi égale